salut à tous ces envergure on est de
retour pour parler de ces portraits de
draft et c'est notre nouveau format de
podcasts que vous avez peut-être
découvert vous pouvez revenir en arrière
sur notre site ou bien sûr au chat ou
sur votre plateforme préférée les
portraits de draft et c'est en 30
minutes le portrait d'un joueur dont on
va parler très probablement au mois de
juin dont le nom va être appelé par adam
silver pour et bien rejoindre la grande
ligue ce soir on parle de mark williams
des longs bras dans la raquette des duke
blue devils une des équipes clairement
les plus en vue de cette saison nba avec
un effectif pléthorique et lui donc dans
la raquette qui contre tout ce qui
bougeait ce qu'il a le potentiel pour
aller en nba et pour y faire carrière
pour y répondre
trois personnes mais d'abord le
spécialiste de la conférence est ici si
où évoluent duke c'est steve salut steve
le média
accompagner pour l'analyse de ben et de
hugues messieurs
seul de tous mark williams il est long
il est très très long le podcast lui ne
durera que 30 minutes c'est parti
[Musique]
alors on vous y habituer ses portraits
de draft et se compose en deux parties
sont composés de partie c'est à dire que
d'abord on va vous faire une carte
d'identité assez sommaire mais pour que
vous sachiez ce qu'il y à savoir deux
plus importants sur le joueur et puis
dans la deuxième partie on va essayer de
se projeter un petit peu voilà
d'évaluer la projection du joueur dans
ses premières années en nba peut-être
dans la suite de sa carrière aussi et
puis je poserai des questions aux trois
spécialistes sur en juste en regardant
la ligne de stats voilà comme n'importe
qui pourrait le faire en gardant juste
les stades sans regarder les matchs en
dix ans bâtir comment ça se fait que
voilà ça sera la deuxième partie pour
l'instant la première partie on commence
à s'intéresser à l'homme ensuite on va
parler de son corps et ensuite on va
parler de ses qualités et donc pour
débuter on va parler de l'homme son
parcours qui est mark williams est à toi
steve donc mark williams et pivot
sophomore des blue devils de duke il est
né le 16 décembre 2009 phoques en
virginie les trois années de high school
dans sa ville d'origine à norfolk à
cabrousse ils finissent à l'arrêt son
lycée en prêt puis school à mj à caligny
en floride un joueur à ses côtés cinq
étoiles ces 240 export des cinquièmes
pivot kaka de sa génération chez nice
peine remis à duke il fait une saison
freshman en deux parties première partie
où ne joue pas départ ensuite de
jenkinson te retrouves avoir beaucoup de
temps de jeu et cette saison ça doit te
la saison de la confirmation pour lui du
côté de la famille il a un père qui est
docteur
ils ont probablement issu d'un milieu
tout favorisé avec un an quelqu'un
culturel important ça serait née
elisabeth williams et joueuses de
brioude billets laetitia duc fait son
cursus complet là bas et à jouer en
europe aussi aux canards batch et
et dernière chose il est d'origine
nigériane en deuxième les familles c'est
au louvre à fesmy ou comme énormément de
pivot nba ouais c'est clair que les
pivots les pivot nigérian c'est quelque
chose qui est devenu courant il y en a
au moins un ou deux par par draft par
cuvée ces dernières années très bien
très complet très clair pour le portrait
de l'homme qui est donc titulaire tu
l'as dit pour cette saison sophomore à
duke entouré on peut le préciser avant
de passer à la suite entouré de deux au
moins trois ou quatre joueurs qui sont
prévues au premier tour de la draft
être totalement franc que joueur à dieu
qui peuvent être pro tour parlons du
corps parlons du corps de mark williams
et là je vais demander à peine de
prendre la parole ben à quoi il
ressemble pas aux spécimens de pivot ici
à la vieille école donc il fait mike
williams en europe et il fait deux
maîtresses à 110 kg avec une envergure
de 2 m à terme ce qui est énorme et un
standing aux riches comment est ce qu'on
dit je crois que ça se dit pas
de mettre
ses pieds 242 livre une envergure de 6,7
est un sandwich de
9,8 juste pour benben à temps pour
expliquer ce temps d'ingrid c'est à dire
côté debout les bras levés donc debout
les bras levés il arrive à 2,94 donc à
11 cm du cercle et dans l'histoire des
mesures mans de la campagne pré draft il
ya seulement quand sa joie qui a mesuré
plus grand que lui et un
tacko fall rudy gobert
d'accord les premiers jusqu'aux 22
points 2e le deuxième temps des pompiers
s'agit de pages un peu de liquide qui
avait été racheté en 2004
les
parlers le jazz de utah qui aimait jouer
deux saisons analyse qui ne savait
absolument pas bouger ce qui n'est pas
le cas de mark williams qui bouge
vraiment très bien dans l'espace qui est
léger sur les appuis qui est capable de
couvrir beaucoup de terrain parce qu'il
est vraiment très long ce qui est un
composant un peu pour son manque de
vitesse c'est pas un gars qui est très
explosif mais
compense en battant les bras dans les
airs en gâchant la vue des joueurs qui
sont plus petits c'est le joueur qui est
à peu près idéal pour jouer ce qu'on
appelle notre droit de cambridge suis en
nba je crois qu'il va avoir beaucoup de
tirs bloqués comme ça
en termes de souris fiabilité j'aime et
j'ai mis d'autres je crois que les élus
à la forme pote george et compagnie vont
avoir on vous fait contre lui surtout en
play-offs mais s'il fait penser un peu à
l'image de son rôle en nba mais si
l'on y les musculeux éléphants et il
bouge bien donc à l'hebdo qu'on lui
demande surtout de couvrir le poste base
qui fait à merveille mais c'est sa
couvrir le pays m
on y viendra plus tard en tout cas pour
le corps on l'a bien compris des
mensurations exceptionnelles au niveau
de la longueur avec une mobilité plus
intéressante que les prospects qui ont
sept longueurs d'habitude pour résumé
hugh
au niveau du jeu qu'est-ce qui fait
assez bien pour la nba aujourd'hui
puisque c'est la troisième partie de
cette carte d'identité c'est toi qui vas
nous décrire un peu à lhassa la casse
son cv quel cv il donne
quand il cote il va arriver à la draft
je crois que ben rhodes écrivant le
physique assez bien expliquée en fait
aux gens ce qu'est ce qu'on va voir ce
qu'on va avoir un pivot assez classique
assez traditionnel qui va être un vrai
protecteur de sac parce qu'il va être
très grand écran alors quand même une
certaine mobilité qui va surtout exister
que me l'a dit notre europe qui va
rester plutôt bas il va accueillir les
portant de balle adverse il va les
écraser contre contre la planche c'est
un joueur qui est assez puissant pour
encaisser du contact il faudra quand
même développé ça c'est pour la défense
il a des bras très très long comme ben
il a expliqué du coup il va pouvoir
aussi cassé des lignes de passes ça va
vraiment être une encre défensive dans
une défense et n'diaye et puis de
l'autre côté du terrain c'est un joueur
qui va en reparler après les écrans qui
va poser des écrans et qui sont unis
comprend bien le jeu de qui va passer il
va rouler va se rendre disponible à
mener de l'agressivité près du panier et
on espère à terme écarter un peu plus
son jeu même si une certaine régression
par rapport à ce à ce secteur depuis
l'an dernier parfait voilà la carte
d'identité de notre ami mark williams
steve je vais commencer par par une
question spécifiquement pour toi mais
est ce que toi toi qui nous disait dans
la présentation fin de saison dernière
il avait commencé à se montrer la
confiance cette saison est-ce que ça se
confirme aussi dans les attitudes est ce
que c'est plus un leader est ce que
c'est quelqu'un qui mène par l'exemple
est ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est plus
conscient de son rôle est qui et qui
fait tout ça silencieusement comment il
se comporte sur le terrain plutôt
anglais plutôt un gars discret
effectivement plus dans son rôle y a pas
hélas pas inapte à la norme aimant vocal
entendent vraiment de faire ce qu'on lui
a demandé les pays-bas expressif sur un
terrain alors que c'est pas un joueur
qui justement quand il va mettre un
conte qui lui arrive régulièrement
souvent va se mettre à affleck ce genre
de choses là il a l'air trés trés focus
sur ce qu'il fait et ça a l'air d'être
un garçon plutôt introverti en tout cas
sur le terrain c'est pas un garçon
explosif
est ce que tu es entendu déjà des
interviews ou pas je pose la question
aussi à benne qui aime bien je passe
tellement bender peu puis je veux dire
ça ça ça donne un peu le miroir de ce
que steve parlait de son road un milieu
privilégié ce à dire qu'il est très bien
entraînés qui les médias ça lui dit pas
vraiment grand chose d'intéressant
mais c'est le revers de la médaille
comme on dit hugues
jeu ça jours qui se comparait qui se
projetaient comme un modèle carter
junior qui était pas non plus un jour
très très expressif donc voilà on a le
ce style là très académique dans le jeu
des jo ratés rang et un relais du coach
comme ça très peu expressif et oui il ya
déjà suffisamment de joueurs expressive
dans cette équipe avec des fortes
personnalités pour que pour que lui ne
viennent pas gâcher tout ça ce qui peut
en faire aussi un bon joueur de
complément nba derrière derrière des des
leaders ma question principale étant
puisque c'est sa force puisque c'est sûr
ça qu'on va le juger
il est classé ou par rapport aux autres
pivots hors
d'haleine dur est né cet homme grain fin
par hors top 10 top 10 15 de la draft
est-ce que c'est lui le premier de votre
de votre longue liste de pivot
protecteur de serbes qui va être
candidat cette année comment il se
classe par rapport aux autres et
pourquoi
hugo ben
ouais alors dans ma liste si je sors de
challenger je crois que je vais l'avoir
quatrième jeu limité regarde soin de
bottes le que j'ai en loterie je les
mythes arrière notre ami moussa diabaté
le français et je les nie par dans une
pure objectivité évidemment derrière
jonathan de siamois de choix
c'est pas défensivement que ce que je
vais le défendre parce que je pense que
ça peut être un des meilleurs
protecteurs de cirque de cette cuvée
c'est plus dans son apport offensif est
dans ce que j'attends d'un pivot nba et
hui en attaque et il a bien pas faire
grand chose mais ce qu'il a à faire il
ne fait pas bien d'après moi donc c'est
pour ça que les baisses beaucoup par
rapport aux autres pivots sais quoi qui
fait pas bien pour aller là on va poser
des écrans c'est un très très très
mauvais posant d'écran je trouve disons
que entend en deuxième année avec ce
corps cette puissance et ce
développement physique qui l'a ne pas
être capable de créer un décalage par
rapport sur le défenseur on écrasant le
défenseur du porteur de balle ça me pose
problème alors il fait très bien ce
qu'il appelle le site roll vraiment
rouler au panier elles sont directement
il va très vite au cirque comme ça et du
coup ils craignent un mètre contact ils
créent gèrent plein décalage est en fait
il sert pas à grand-chose du coup notre
style est ce que tu confirmes ou est ce
que tu trouves c'est un peu dur c'est
aussi la faute des gardes qui sont les
ports c'est difficile à duke puisque les
porteurs de ballon sont pas des vrais
meneurs n'y a pas de vrai meneur
habituel joue bien et je suis assez
d'accord avec hugues et aussi peut-être
effectivement la question des choix qui
sont faits sur les formes de jeu en
attaque ou youtube même sans mark
williams ne jouent pas voir seulement
beaucoup pick and roll après c'est vrai
qu'il est toujours quasiment sûr de
l'écran slip et aussi les impôts ce
problème une parler aussi de
développement musculaire ce qu'on n'a
pas forcément dit quand on a parlé de
son corps et qu' il a énormément pris
entre sa première et sa deuxième année
sur le haut du corps donc autant l'année
dernière il était peut-être encore un
peu fort pour avoir confiance sur ses
pose d'écrans autant cette saison et a
vraiment pris au niveau des épaules et
il devrait être capable effectivement
comme début elle est impacté les
défenseurs sont porteurs de balle pour
créer vraiment des situations de
contrats temporaires sur des situations
pick and roll et aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que il épouse pas et c'est aussi
peut-être des choix de votre coaching
tiens c'est là l'intérêt pour les forces
de contact exactement est ce que l'un
d'entre vous a vu mark williams dans
d'autres contacts
non mais c'est pas facile à trouver moi
non plus
mais ça sera intéressant à voir
effectivement ben
on reste sur le l'attaquent on passera à
la défense question on peut le dire son
point fort ensuite sur le côté défensif
offensivement on dit qu'il se lit
beaucoup les écrans qu'est ce qui fait
une fois qu'il a le ballon en main quand
on lui donne le ballon est ce qu est ce
qui fait les choses bien parce que lui
disait il pose pas bien les écrans mais
on peut aussi l'imaginer en ce que ce
qui est ce que doit faire parfois qui
veulent lui ni par exemple du côté de
golden state à jouer des 4 contre 3
parce que il ya un très bon shooteur à
qu'il a posé un écran juste avant qu'ils
aient slip et un écran quoi c'est ces
domaines qui est quand même assez
imposant je crois qu'il ya une mission
je crois je m'abuse de 67 pour ça au
panier c'est à peu près la totalité
c'est pas ni
la totalité des paniers qui prend
juste à peu près ce que
mike williams fait c'est pas un shooter
incroyable avec des lacets fera je crois
qu'il est à 65 % cette année une
amélioration là dessus mais ce ne sera
jamais
en situation de match point mauvais pas
sa
passion il est capable il est calme avec
le ballon invaincu lors des prises de
lui capable de de prendre le ballon en
main et réfléchir donc ce jeu des deux
fois ça mais on sait ce qu'on a on dit
c'est ce qu'on achète on achète un
brûleur on achète joie est pas un
produit fini cuit qui va observer à
hugues tutu lui faisait remarquer dans
le chat de ce podcast que il avait
baissé son volume de midrange en est ce
qui peut faire autre chose que
simplement faire du reamonn comme on dit
c'est ça le truc c'est que l'an dernier
en fait j'avais de gros espoirs pour lui
parce que mais ce soir l'avancé et puis
je le voyais dans une situation de rôle
ou bien au rang d'une zone est capable
d'attraper le ballon est tout simplement
de mettre un petit sert à mi-distance
celui la ligne des lancers francs il
avait une efficacité assez correct il
court sans forcer sur ce secteur-là avec
eux c'était à peu près un tiers un quart
de siècle cette année les plus du tout
je sais pas pourquoi est ce que c'est le
système que me disent estivaux est-ce
que c'est pas en confiance et du coup
y'a pas d'efficacité
1 4 4 sur 13 sur les deux points l'on
sait ça et j'ai poussé pas beaucoup quoi
j'ai pas le chiffre l'an dernier mais
voilà il y avait quand même beaucoup
plus de tirs star des premier truc que
j'avais noté avec ma passe comme le
disait ben et il y en a pas et un mec
qui progresse pas là-dessus qui prend
pas plus en confiance ça peut gêner ça
peut le bc donc donc voilà à surveiller
mais pour l'heure tout ce que dit ban au
niveau du cercle oise est un média 75%
près du panier ce qui est très bien sans
être élite élite par rapport aux
intérieurs mais c'est quand même très
bien alors j'ai 72 chez barthes or vic
mais parfois ils ont un match de retard
et dans le staff messin 72% ça reste
très très bien j'ai une question pour
steve
26 % de fruits frais totaux de lancers
francs pour un joueur de ce calibre
de 7,2 cette dimension là je trouve ça
très faible est ce que c'est un joueur
qui rechignent au contact et pas ton
confort je pense qu'il ya un peu soft
riz manque de dureté donc un peu de
dureté activement maintenant c'est un
peu près 50 ans pour les joueurs de son
profil il va pas assez sur la ligne
ça ça fait partie du site et des défauts
ceci peut-être pour ça qu'ils posent pas
beaucoup d'écrans aussi voilà il ya ce
rapport contacter pas forcément petit
match et nuit parce que voilà et puis
pour le us pour revenir sur le tiers moi
personnellement je ne crois pas du tout
pense que il fera pas capable de
s'écarter que par contre malaga sera
intéressant sur sur du lobe cérébrale
mais je ne crois pas du tout faits garp
et en attaque parce que il a à 15%
contre donc les gens pourraient se dire
c'est contre là ça veut dire qu'ils
aiment le contact mais quand on regarde
les matches c'est souvent du second
rideau ou du jeu laisse passer le mec
pourra utiliser mais mais immense bras
et le surprendre compte la planche quoi
ça c'est pas c'est pas en fait il est
suffisamment grand louvre encore plus en
wifi il n'y a pas beaucoup de pivot de
sept pieds pour pouvoir contrer sent
fortement allez allez justement sur sur
les contacts sans être hyper agressif
sur le contact est séparé en attaque sur
une situation de loeb on le touche même
pas quasiment donc on fait il n'est pas
en train d'écraser des dogues sur les
mecs j'ai utilisé beaucoup plus grand en
fait donc les portes à l'adaptation nba
l'affairé question reste posée c'est ça
ben est ce que on a beaucoup d'exemples
de joueurs qui savent faire que du riz
me redonne vraiment que que dure imran
qui chute à moins de 70 % aux lancers
francs aussi l'on soit il janiak bien
trouve que vincent un peu plus soft et
ses dialogues drôles
c'est une avec lui on achète
le bon marché
physiquement
plus intéressant vu la longueur
peut-être coach abl mais il manque un
petit peu du
des crocs de diane bedu holden par
exemple un peu de la méchanceté de gaza
on pourrait devenir avant mais
c'est à peu près ce que celle de
journaux mais de charles robinson
qui ne s'est absolument pas mettre des
craintes mais qu'il lui a décroché à new
york
un très bon boulot sans doute malgré les
maquilleuses d'habitation qu'est ce que
vous voyez que c'est les joueurs il faut
reliques qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces comparaisons
messieurs steve et hull et guy
hoquet
oui bah moi il l'est moins effectivement
au niveau de la mentalité l'est beaucoup
moins agressif moins dur que des regrets
jordan après sur le rôle qu'on veut lui
accorder effectivement je me vois dans
ce style le rôle d'argan après je pense
quand même un peu plus fin dans la
compréhension du jeu et d andré jordan
ne le pense un peu plus passeur hausse
qui peut pas mieux utilisé la balle il
est beaucoup utilisé sur des situations
de cordes ou qui touchent les ballons au
niveau des coudes il est capable de
créer la continuité quand même dit
capable de jouer derrière sur dumas il
est capable de donner un une bonne passe
pour un joueur qui va couper backdoor
par exemple ne t'avais pas forcément un
mec comme viendrait jordan mais ouais un
des entraîneurs donnent un peu moins
méchant ya peut-être un peu plus un peu
plus qu'au tchad un peu plus fin voilà
un peu moins athlétiques aussi quand
même ouais ouais ouais mais un peu plus
intelligent ouais
alors j'ai une question parle de sa
protection de cercle
c'est vraiment une question qui m'est
venue en regardant en regardant du film
qu'est ce qui fait de lui un meilleur
protecteur de serre que d'autres dans
cette draft et à son poste d'où ma
question de base avec la comparaison des
autres et moussa diabaté dit john butler
eu que toi tu le classent derrière
pourquoi est-ce que défensivement pour
toi il va être aussi moins bon que les
deux que j'ai précédemment cités moussa
diabaté john butler homogène du renne
on parle d'un joueur que vous avez tous
décrits et qui le monde cette saison
très très efficaces en europe je
rappelle le chiffre qui est vraiment
très impressionnant 15% de tirs adverses
bloqués quand il est sur le terrain
non je pense qu'il sera plus efficace
que john butler qui est un profit ont
été très fin et qui adore soutien sur
les petits seins pivot quitté fond comme
amr donc un câble après très particulier
pour moi ce que marc wilhem fait très
très bien comme tu le dis dans le dans
la drogue sait qu'il va orienter d'un
seul côté et j'aime bien peut-être plus
que bn sa mobilité latéral pour
accompagner du coup son porteur
extérieur jusqu'au panier et surtout ce
que je veux a lu énormément cher un
protecteur de cercle comme lui c'est
qu'il est capable de changer de mains
pour contester le tir je m'explique
imaginons il aya le bras droit pour
contester un lay up ils voient que le
défenseur l'attaquant change de
direction et va partir sur son côté
gauche et bat tout de suite il va
changer travail à mettre la main gauche
pour contester bloqués ou en tout cas
changer la direction tout ça sans faire
de faute aux récents très très verticale
et là vraiment un sens du timing
défensif ne l'anticipaient sur la
compréhension très très impressionnant
pour son âge
et pour son profil je valide eu cette
observation j'ai aussi remarqué qu'ils
savaient contrer des deux mains ce qui
est extrêmement rare ce que nous disait
d'ailleurs
jcpraz temps dans un des premiers
planète draft il essayait de faire
contrer ce mail kamagaté dès demain
et c'est pas quelque chose de naturel
j'ai beaucoup de joueurs c'est même
impossible et lui mark williams peut le
faire plus souvent main droite mais je
l' ai vu faire des contres avec ça avec
sa main gauche j'aime aussi bien parce
que vous en pensez le fait qu'ils
puissent tourner les hanches c'est à
dire que parfois il effectivement il en
retard il a des hanches un peu hot donc
il se fait crosser mais il se retourna
c'est bien en tout cas il est rarement
en retard à voir si en nba
le retard qui ici se ans et 6,6 va se
concrétiser par un lay up va pas se
transformer en dunk qui est beaucoup
moins contre abl justement on va passer
à sa projection
année 1,2 en nba parce que pour les
déjà vous vous l'avez ou dans vos
classements je sais pas steve situe si
tu as un petit un big board ou pas mais
une nous parler de fin de premier tour
ben aussi tu la fin de premier tour faye
3 24e ouest il
moi je suis pas de big board qu'est ce
que je vois pas assez de mathieu
conférence voilà bah forcément le cp
difficilement institué ou alors sur une
idée de drag moyenne quoi ouais et donc
tue-le tue-le placerait aussi dans ces
eaux-là par rapport à ce qui se trouve
en nba aujourd'hui
entre 20 et 30
du coût entre 20 et 30 ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'il soit assez efficace
assez rapidement en tout cas c'est
souvent ce qu'on demande aux joueurs
draftés dans ces eaux là entre 20 et 40
soit et efficace rapidement soit tu
dégages assez vite de l'effectif est ce
qu'il peut l'être je commence par ben
ben écoutez moi je vous sers à l'article
tous les joies de la nuit ont essayé de
défoncer au contact l'année l'année
prochaine je crois qu'il va avoir
beaucoup de difficulté à s'adapter dans
ses premières années je peux le
comprendre et devront prendre beaucoup
de dureté beaucoup rapidement parce que
ce genre de
deux spécimens c'est éclater tout le
monde c'est celle de spécialement les
pivots vous allez voir vous allez voir
jouer le bide essayé de défoncer avec
ses épaules je crois que ça va être au
départ pivot qui voit ce qu'on appelle
un check-up asky un prélat boban
marjanovic quand il fonctionne on voit
sur le terrain pour changer le lieu mais
là j'ai oublié dans le match paris le 5
à 10 minutes par match je crois qu'il
croit que
très bien très bien den
hugues même question même constat ou pas
ouais je rejoins bense c'est un peu mon
maître là dessus comme si je pense qu il
va jouer huit minutes trente ans pour
casser moi je comprends mal à te dit
bradley donc séparé tu va casser du
rythme grande protéger quand on small
ball il fonctionne pas et paraître
espaces verts à s'écraser au contact au
début mais c'est tony bradley il sait
mettre des écrans
ah oui tony bradley s'est hissée mettre
des écrans il fait tout le temps faute
offensive mais au moins il fait mal à
l'adversaire et ça ça n'a pas été dans
mon équipe je prends
mais voilà c'est un cinq gars qui va
mettre un petit peu de temps à son
niveau on sait que c'est plus long mais
qu'il ya un physique pour pouvoir jouer
comme tu vois tu disais en 20 30 des
pivots
pour les équipes fonctionnelles notre
ami du rhône sharp l'an dernier prépare
brooklyn
bon bah voilà peut-être ce genre de
profil là pour lui ce genre de rôle la
très limitée mais qui peut entrer at est
intéressant ça steve toi qui était déjà
sur la liste ici l'année dernière par
rapport à un d'iron sharp comment tu le
situe défensivement par rapport à
l'impact qu'ils pourraient avoir à court
terme dans une ligue plus physique
et pas du tout les mêmes joueurs charpy
lille beaucoup plus trapu ramasser et
justement le contacter au contraire il
est hyper l'aise avec ça
je pense que william servat et à une
adaptation
l'ont donc effectivement plus de temps
mais que peut-être qu'il sera plus
efficace sur le long terme que derrick
sharp
mais toi tu la longueur la mobilité
whisky ce qui m'intéressait aussi tu
disais tu crois pas aux tirs est ce que
c'est une question de mécanique ou c'est
vraiment une question de bages regarde
les résultats et ça n'évolue pas quoi
comme ugl en parallèle au niveau des
tentatives de delon de points on se sait
la mécanique et les deux d'entre eux te
dire c'est les deux et c'est
effectivement le fait qu'ils tirent pas
déjà sur move et cynthia gauthier tirés
notamment les remous lancers francs et
les mauvais la gt est bonne il a les
pieds dans le ciment le triple à il n'a
pas du tout aimé canicule très
performante tu penses que ospina il va
pas énormément développé ça peut-être
qu'une huile et francis qui vont le
draft est justement a été oh oui c'est
de le développer mais en tout cas
personnellement je pense pas que ce soit
aux normes soirée qui va pouvoir compter
dans les années à venir ben non plus
s'ils croient pas
tu crois que je crois que
ce genre de joueur dont on achète pour
certaines raisons puis je crois que si
on le voit en train de pratiquer son tir
moutons je sais pas à liu d'envoi lui
taper sur les toiles on peut pratiquer à
bloquer des tirs à la place pourquoi tu
le prennes on veut tous les blocs
poil faqdd allocs
etc et kelenna azubuike et où d'aucuns
feeling the brick et les anciens ceux de
migros surprise
est parti
il est venu rejoindre les knicks
azubuike lui aussi nigérian comme mark
williams est d'origine nigériane où là
nous a dit steve bien sûr toutes les
connexions sont là
azubuike qui a pas beaucoup de temps de
jeu on espère que ce sera mieux pour
mark williams mais moi vous m'avez pas
vraiment convaincu dans le portrait que
vous m'avez dressé je vois pas un joueur
du top 30 faire sans
[Musique]
nom mais c'est intéressant parce qu'il a
la grosse cote il a fait un super match
face à gonzaga façade chez tom graines
etc ça lui a quand même fait gagner des
points donc donc c'est vrai que c'est
un joueur qui a du potentiel mais en
même temps est-ce qu'il ya la place et
surtout est ce qu'un coach va adapter
son système pour un joueur comme ça
parce que c'est un joueur pour lequel il
faut presque adapter son système ça fait
sa manière de défendre les ai grandi à
kankan marque qui rentre on défend un
drop du coup les gars ça on s'en
rappelle et ce qui peut faire autre
chose que le drop ce sera ma dernière
question à échéance trois quatre cinq
ans
je pense que oui
badens excusez moi ah ouais je pense que
oui parce qu'il peut sortir quand même
sur des petits le fait quand même assez
bien il sort et après il revient donc on
est des reproches qui peut être assez
efficace genre de la trappe or un peu
d'agressivité tout en taux non sur le
côté il peut il peut faire ça quand même
parfait et bien un chiffre à retenir 2
mètre 94 c'est la taille de mark
williams debout les bras levés
c'est quand même difficile donc aux eaux
au pire on le verra sans doute gêné les
remises en jeu pour les matchs cote
quand le score sera serré merci beaucoup
monsieur pour ce scouting les portes de
mark williams dans le prochain épisode
on parlera de michael bay vaut le joueur
de georgia tech en attendant si vous
pouvez aller voir des matchs de duke il
ya des prospects à l'appel comme on l'a
dit banques et rockies griffin notre ami
mark williams wendell moore et même les
joueurs qui sortent du banc seront sans
doute pro quelque part
dans donc donc voilà n'hésitez pas merci
merci merci messieurs merci les boys
tumen et à bientôt sur envergure pour de
nouvelles aventures